Szerintem ez bennem nem kérdés, tehát
hogy mindenképp azt gondolom, hogy
mindenki jobb lesz attól. Akár itt
eszembe jut például Nagy Ervinnel néztem
annó egy interjút, és ő mondta el azt,
hogy soha nem tudott addig például sírni
színpadon, amíg nem született meg a
lánya, és utána ez így sikerült. Én most
ennyire konkrét példát nem tudok
felhozni. Viszont azt gondolom, hogy az,
hogy valaki anya lesz, valaki apa lesz,
egy új minőséget hoz az életébe, egy
mélyebb megélést, egy egy olyan plusz
kapaszkodót, ami ami minden egyes
mozdulatában utána benne lesz. És és
ezek a ezek az elmélyültebb dolgok
persze, hogy hozzátesznek egy emberhez.
És ha hozzátesznek egy emberhez, akkor
hozzátesznek a színészhez is, és ezáltal
hozzátesznek ahhoz, ahogy ő egy
karaktert meg tud jeleníteni a
színpadon. Én azt hiszem, hogy mélyítik
az embert az ilyenfajta megélések.